cho báo independent Turkey của Thôi Nhật Khi, sất bản ngày 25 thống bởi giữa trên các mồn tiền ngoại giao.
Bong đăng phang chực tiếp thứ ba dựng á bụ quay nà có thể dễ dễ dàng vàng của tôi này trong ngày 25 hóc ngày 25 thống bởi tại thành phủ Istanbul.
Theo thông báo chụi đỏ của tổng thống Uquay nà ở Bulu dis LESC.
Thôi cấp của ông đồng thời là Thôi Khi hội đồng án đing và cú phòng quay nà.
Ông Rút Stam của Merok đã chuyển tựng á để sốt tổ chức của các tiếp theo.
Dưa 2 phải đoạn hai nước bảo tổn tự, mừng tín trong đoạn đà phang nha đã xong nhận thông tin trên
với hàng tin ria của ngà và cho biết tín hiểu từ kép đăng tạo hi vọng về cả năng đà phán sẻ sơm đe ra.
Tuy nhiên hiện chưa dọ thành phần cuộc thề của hai đoạn đà phán.
Ngà vụ quay nà đã tiến hành hai bòng đà phán chức tiếp tại Istan Luôn,
với kết quả là các thỏ thận chào độ tụi bình và chào trả thi thế các bình sĩ từ nhanh.
Mọi gia hai mình cũng đã chào đồ dự tạo hi vọng về giải pháp,
trong rất cuộc sống đồ bông đã kéo giải hình bà nông qua.